Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
La capoeira è un’arte marziale.
Nasce in Brasile, dagli schiavi africani.
I quali, dopo giornate di lavoro forzato,
venivano riportati nelle Zenzala,
che erano delle vere prigioni.
E all'interno di questi spazi,
hanno dato vita alla capoeira,
come un momento importante
per rilassare il corpo e la mente.
E per riuscire anche, in qualche modo,
in una situazione così difficile,
a immaginare un futuro di libertà.
Quindi veramente possiamo dire
che la capoeira nasce
come lotta di liberazione.
Io inizio il mio percorso
nella capoeira 12 anni fa,
presso la scuola accademia
"Sul Da Bahia" a Milano.
Il mio insegnante: Mestrando Pedro,
allievo di Mestre Railson.
Che cosa mi ha affascinato
tantissimo della capoeira?
È un’arte.
È un’arte profonda.
C’è la lotta, quindi c'è la competizione;
ma c’è l’unione,
c'è la musica, c’è la danza,
c’è il canto, c’è la cultura.
E quindi, nella sua armonia,
veramente sono riuscito a trovare
qualcosa di importante,
che riusciva a dare pace
a più parti diverse di me.
Il Burkina Faso, altrettanto,
è un paese importante nella mia vita,
ci viaggio da più di 20 anni.
È un Paese duro,
come la maggior parte dei Paesi
dell'Africa subsahariana, e non solo.
Le situazioni di disagio,
non sono qua adesso oggi
a raccontarle: sono evidenti.
Nel 2009 nasce con un gruppo di amici,
di persone stupende,
l'associazione Kolon Kandya Italia Onlus
che si dedica veramente a due obiettivi:
progetti di impresa sociale
e progetti di inclusione sociale.
Perché?
Perché dall'esperienza, dalla sensibilità,
dalla capacità di viaggiare
e di stare con le persone,
ci rendevamo conto che erano
i due punti cardine
su cui costruire dei progetti.
Impresa sociale
perché l'impresa, il lavoro,
non è solo reddito e dignità.
È confronto.
E inclusione sociale, perché
è necessario lavorare con i giovani.
Perché i giovani sono il nostro futuro,
non solo in Burkina Faso.
Ed è proprio all’interno
di questo contesto,
che nel 2012 inizia
il progetto di capoeira
con il beneplacet fondamentale
di Mester Railson e di Mestrando Pedro,
che sono i supervisori
della parte tecnica.
L'associazione, ovviamente,
con entusiasmo ha abbracciato
questo progetto.
Perché?
Perché la capoeira
diventa il fulcro, lo strumento
per un progetto educativo molto più ampio.
Perché proprio per la sua poliedricità,
la capoeira ci permette
di lavorare con i ragazzi,
perché è intrigante.
C’è la lotta, c’è l’acrobatica,
c’è la disciplina.
Però c’è il sorriso.
Mi piace dire, a volte, che la capoeira
è proprio educare con il sorriso.
E c’è la musica,
c'è la storia, c’è la cultura.
E quindi hai talmente tante cose
con cui attrarre i ragazzi,
e con loro costruire
un percorso di fiducia.
Senza fiducia non si possono
fare percorsi insieme,
e tanto più con i giovani.
E ad oggi, 2016, quindi dopo sei anni,
questo progetto è qualcosa di solido,
con gli sforzi di tutti,
veramente di tutti.
È una scuola:
oggi abbiamo 53 allievi di capoeira,
che vanno dai 6 anni ai 22,
che frequentano ogni settimana
i corsi di capoeira.
E possiamo dire che il centro,
giù, nella seconda città,
a Bobo-Dioulasso, dove abbiamo la sede,
che è la seconda città del Burkina Faso,
questo centro è diventato un po’
un punto di riferimento nel quartiere,
per i giovani e anche
per le loro famiglie.
Questa è una soddisfazione enorme.
Conoscere ogni volto,
ogni ragazzo, ogni nome.
La quadratura del cerchio
di questo progetto
è sicuramente il momento del festival -
o batizado, nel gergo della capoeira.
Ossia il momento in cui, ogni anno,
Mestre Railson e Mestrando Pedro
scendono in Burkina Faso
e c’è un evento, che è bellissimo,
perché è un momento multiculturale.
Ci sono ospiti che arrivano
da più parti del mondo,
è un momento in cui
i ragazzi sono protagonisti,
perché danno una mano nell'organizzazione,
ed è il momento in cui
Mestre Railson, e Mestrando Pedro
fanno l'esame ai ragazzi
per vedere il loro livello di capoeira,
perché non è un regalo.
È capoeira, è disciplina, è arte marziale,
non ce lo dobbiamo dimenticare.
E quindi è emozione: per tutti,
e per i ragazzi prima di tutto.
Sicuramente, in questa fase,
il ruolo di Kolon Kandya è fondamentale,
perché è un supporto necessario, economico
per permettere la realizzazione
del batizado, il festival, e di più.
Perché tutti i ragazzi
che superano l'esame
possono godere del sostegno scolastico,
che è altrettanto importante,
la parte educativa,
riuscire a terminare le scuole.
Non solo là, ovunque.
È la base per costruire
uomini consapevoli, donne consapevoli.
E devo dire che tutta questa parte
è la parte più interessante.
Chiudo con un aneddoto.
Una sera,
dopo un grosso, importante
e bellissimo allenamento di capoeira,
i ragazzi mi hanno chiesto:
“ma perché ci insegni la capoeira?”.
E non potevo raccontargli
dell'importanza come strumento
educativo a dei ragazzi.
E ho cercato di trovare nel fondo,
nel mio più profondo, la parte più intima
che cosa è per me la capoeira,
e qual è la cosa per cui credo
che sia veramente uno strumento
[valido] con i ragazzi.
E ho iniziato così:
“Ragazzi, pensate agli schiavi.
Provate per un attimo soltanto
a mettervi nei loro panni.
È la situazione peggiore,
per un essere umano.
Non hai libertà.
E invece di finire ad abbruttirsi,
a dare il peggio di sé,
hanno dato vita alla capoeira.
A qualcosa che permette,
attraverso un gioco, una disciplina,
di immaginare un futuro migliore,
un futuro di libertà.
E quindi spero per voi, ragazzi,
che questa cosa, la capoeira,
sia un vostro punto di forza.
Perché avrete mille momenti
in cui sarete giù di morale,
avrete dei momenti di difficoltà.
E spero proprio che in quei momenti
la capoeira possa, con la sua disciplina,
essere veramente
una strada maestra per voi."
E adesso,
un po' della magia della capoeira.
Grazie.
(Applausi)